Hey I have very interesting news for
many people in our audience gnihton /
Guam / that other guy / Tom is coming
back and he is developing his own
YouTube channel so a lot of you won't
even remember who gnihton is Anat on
Pakman my brother was the TV director
for the David Pakman show years ago in
fact I would say he is responsible for
the fact that the David Pakman show
exists in video form both on television
and on YouTube because he was the
initial guy who got us up and running on
those platforms figured out how we're
gonna film the show how are we gonna
record the show getting it all up on
YouTube and to TV stations he was an
occasional voice on the show I know that
folks like the Eggman always really
liked Natanz participation he left some
years ago his name was often
misunderstood as either Tom or Tom or
some people would just call him the
other guy meaning yeah not me but also
not Lois like the other that other guy
is how he was referred to a running joke
that you guys all had I like it yeah
although it really it was more the
audience that we followed the audience's
lead on it because they didn't seem to
know exactly what his name was
anyway Newton is back he has had a
clamoring for creating some content
people in the audience have been
emailing saying we know that we can
watch Lewis when he does live streams of
him playing video games very very
exciting stuff wearing huge headphones
by the way if you haven't seen it I do
recommend it when is 'not on going to
start creating some content and he's
back with a YouTube channel it's a brand
new ok you have the opportunity to be
one of the early subscribers to his
channel like maybe you were one of the
early subscribers to my channel his
channel is called Natanz notes Natanz
notes and he offers two to five-minute
explanations of all sorts of historical
events one example okay the JFK
assassination take a look in other words
Oswald fled the scene of the crime left
his job in the middle of the day and
appeared anxious about being identified
and followed but most incriminating of
all 45 minutes
for the assassination Oswald killed
Dallas police officer JD Tippit who had
stopped him as he walked on the street
presumably because he matched the
description witness Howard Brennan had
made of a man who had fired shots at
Kennedy from the sixth floor of the
School Book Depository fifteen minutes
later
Oswald entered a movie theater without
paying for a ticket which was noticed by
a witness
shortly after Dallas police entered the
theater as officer Nick McDonald got
close to him Oswald punched him in the
face and drew his revolver to try to
shoot him only to be subdued and
arrested by several Dallas police
officers so you've got history on Natanz
notes you have some science discussing
the question of whether time travel is
possible the same is true of the effects
of gravity the higher the gravitational
pull on an object or person the slower
the time will pass compared with others
at a lower gravitational pull if you saw
the movie interstellar you'll remember
that this is a crucial part of the plot
so if you go near a massive black hole
or on a planet with more gravity than
that of earth and then come back home
everyone on earth will have aged much
more than you so there it is please
subscribe to him on YouTube like
comments say the David Pakman show sent
you all that stuff it's kind of hard to
find the channel because the URL is a
crazy string of it's like youtube.com
slash all sorts of crazy stuff so you
can either Google search or youtube
search Natanz notes or we are gonna link
to it in the description to our youtube
clip so some people will be delighted
others will be extraordinarily dismayed
to hear that former TV director in
Atanas back and you can be one of the
early subscribers the channel has just
recently launched how excited would you
say you are about this path like is this
are you gonna now go to sleep while
listening to these video clips yeah I'm
gonna have to catch up on all of them I
think I think it's just more exciting to
learn that you have a brother I mean who
knew that it I know it's shocking to
some people how could I come from
anything other than the circumstances of
an only child that will be very very
shocking to mental health professionals
all over the world
I'm sure